boo it's me I'm back where does YouTube
send new viewers in
2023. I've been doing this for
four years
four five I don't know no one's here yet
I'm doing this one live because I am
biased and if you're watching this from
the future this is an explanation for
you I am very biased I am no longer new
I'm no longer a new viewer therefore
anything that I pick does not qualify as
where YouTube would send a new viewer
because I'm not new hello welcome if
you're just joining us hi I'm alive yes
I am 100 you can believe that it's
definitely not a lie how are you doing
I'm fine I had a great Christmas and a
great New Year's but we've got important
things to get to so everyone come to
order immediately
that probably was annoying for years
we're going to do something very
important
we're going to be doing research we're
going to be doing intellectual very
studious research which means that I
need all of you to be at your top game I
need you to all activate every brain
cell that you have left to be able to
help me deduce exactly what it's like to
be a new viewer because I know for a
fact probably probably not YouTube is
going to take this in
and understand it that's what they've
been doing and they've been referencing
my past videos where I've done this
exact thing together with you so that
they can figure out how to make YouTube
a better place for all of us okay sound
good
yes I have everything private I'm on a
VPN everything should be very very basic
and I'm looking at the suggested videos
that I have right here and I think it's
a nice variety it just definitely shows
I don't think any of these that I've
actually watched before so this seems to
be generally speaking a new slate here
what we're gonna do
what we're gonna do
what we're gonna do yeah you gotta you
gotta I don't know if you have to crank
your brain cells up or crank your brain
cells down to become a new viewer
imagine you don't have any viewing
habits at all everyone take this
opportunity to delete your internet
history just as a reminder that you
probably should do that because you
never know what's going to happen and
the last thing that you want is your
family going through your internet
history trying to look for all your
passwords to get all your accounts it's
just not going to be good for anybody so
try to do whatever you need to do with
your brain cells independently to be
able to get them where they need to be
so that we can get into this with fresh
eyes okay I'm counting on you this is
the first time that I've done this live
usually I've done it in the past just by
myself trying to make this happen and
I've had to dynamically adjust my
intelligence as I go along to try to be
a new viewer I mean let's be honest I
have to dumb it down a bit from my
incredible brain but for now I'm going
to turn my big brain off so that you
guys can Channel your tiny brains and we
can all get through this together okay
all right your brain cells have gone I
don't know if that means it's good or
bad
why are we doing why are we doing this
why do we do anything on this channel
why do we do anything on the internet
why for content sweet delicious content
that we are stealing from everyone else
who has done a lot of hard work to make
this content and I'm going to be using
it and taking it as my own and I'm going
to be making a video about it making
content about it so that I can look good
in comparison to everybody there you are
joining me because you have a vested
interest in making YouTube a good place
and by association you get to do
something good and I will steal all your
ideas I will tasteful content I don't
know about that I don't know if it'll be
tasteful
I don't know at all only fans drop three
will be happening eventually I've just
got back I literally just got back from
Christmas
yeah
what is happening
I literally just explained it but if you
need me to explain it again I guess I
will
we're gonna be doing the video if you've
seen my videos in the past you know what
this is about
I'm talking a lot without saying much I
am saying
my microphone fell I'm sorry I am saying
exactly what we're doing I'm not talking
a lot and saying a little I'm talking a
lot and saying a lot
I told you to turn your brains off I
turned you why we're going to be doing
this we're doing this because we do this
every year and because I have this thing
about trying to do things every year and
kind of like making it a regular thing
eventually I'm gonna do like what is
steam's lowest rated game again in this
year just to see if there's anything
worse about it
and that's what we're going to do okay
so turn off your brains you guys are
thinking way too much just just turn off
turn off your brain just turn off your
brain no yeah small it's small brain
time there we go brains are off you're
waking up early in the morning one day
your friend told you about this website
called it YouTube you've never heard of
this thing before you've never heard of
anything like it but you hear that there
might be some entertaining funny videos
on this okay
you decide to type into your browser
youtube.com and what comes up boom
the home page
the suggested videos are all here no no
don't think thinking is not good
thinking not good thinking is bad
thinking is is not what we're trying to
do here we go to worst mistake of my
life
how bad was it was it that bad
oh yeah whoa yeah right okay this is new
oh
my god wow okay let your brain wander
let your brain wander your eyes are
being drawn to something on the screen
right your eyes are drawn you don't know
what it is you don't know what any of
this means you don't even know what a
thumbnail is you don't know what view
counts are all you know is that you want
content right what are we look what are
we what are we watching go
go you're jumping into it there's no
explanation there's no me waiting and
vamping go what are we what are we doing
what are we doing
undertale
no
you don't know what undertale is you
don't know you don't you you don't know
because you haven't watched your
favorite anybody ever play it right
no no
is that what you really want
the face there face armor see okay face
armor you see Cafe music okay that's I
don't think I can play that and that's a
28 hour video
this is this is the 28 hour vid is it
because you can't see the one that's
behind my head okay wait there's another
one behind my head
how to cook and feed for over 3 000
Japanese students oh well they're pretty
good
okay what are we watching
okay all right
wow this is really split okay you guys
aren't I thought you would all like as
new viewers I thought you would kind of
like funnel towards just one and it
seems to be the undertale one but I am
really putting that aside so what I'm
gonna do is you're gonna give me and I'm
gonna select it down to a top three and
then we're gonna pick from there we're
gonna use the polling system to be able
to do this because otherwise I'm not
going to be able to count what you're
doing but as you can see
I have a power of a veto if you can see
this moving around there think of it
like shiny Keys jingle jingle I have
vetoes I can veto what you're saying but
only three times right because I do have
a say in this I've turned off my brain
and therefore I can kind of get an idea
of what this is going to be okay all
right so we're going to do a poll
I'm gonna put undertale on there because
whatever all right what this is the
first video everybody this is the first
video that we're watching and therefore
this is going to paint a picture of
every other video that we watch every
single other video
okay
all right okay well let me just let me
just I'll put them on here
looking
uh
all right some of you wanted the
the bulletproof mask
okay some of you wanted
I saw a lot of people for the
professional
whatever that is okay so that's as many
as I can put here I didn't really see a
lot of people that were looking for
other ones so I'm gonna ask this this is
the poll is up now you guys decide what
it is we're looking at and we'll just
remember this is going to literally
paint every single thing that we see
from this time on
ooh
ooh okay
interesting
interesting
fascinating and what what is interesting
here is because it seems to be the
majority of people are going for the
bulletproof mask and that is the video
with the most views on here I didn't put
World Cup if I put World Cup on my
channel I will be sued out of existence
I literally won't exist anymore and then
I won't not be able to do anything here
okay so I can't do that
I can't do that I can't do the World Cup
because no matter what when it comes
down to sports there's no one that will
ever ever be able to make me do what it
like what I do anymore I'll be shut down
forever
okay all right
so shockingly it looks like the
bulletproof mask is going to win but I
want to know why I want to know why
we're doing research here I wanted you
to dig turn your brains back on and then
think very carefully what was it about
the bulletproof armor video that made
you want to click on it because clearly
according to democracy here you guys
wanted to see that video
about a coward I think this is this is
democracy just because I have veto
Powers doesn't mean that I'm this is
unfair this is what you guys picked and
it's by a big margin too it's 35 to 26
which is tied between undertale and
cooking for Japan so no matter how vocal
the minority of the people that want to
watch undertale is it's still it's not
even beating cooking for Japan
bulletproof stuff guns it looks cool the
mask is cool violence Tech
I guess that is an interesting thing it
does kind of blend across a few
different things it's got what could be
Tech
guns I guess
and then generally speaking you're
testing something so there's kind of
like an end result curiosity to it that
is fascinating
all right everybody in agreement this is
the first video that we're gonna watch
I'm not going to veto it
America Echo pew pew yeah okay uh
interesting fascinating
all right good shades all right
sunglasses does the mask work yeah that
is a good question okay I want to know
if the mask works that's a good point
we're gonna watch this
I can't see in this thing today on
Grantham
do these work
I actually have no idea so the Black
Rifle podcast okay spoiler we're just
gonna go ahead look I love this new
feature I know this is divisive like
there's there's things that YouTube has
done that kind of like ruin a lot of
things like getting rid of the dislike
button I don't know why that's a thing
uh but I'm going to
I like I love the fact that we can just
see what it do so who wants a slow-mo of
this being shot oh it's already been
shot hang on hold on here we go
way shape or form speed bees here we go
oh my God
oh my God
that exited
oh never mind yeah I did oh never mind
see like so this did fall but the round
split and looks like it went through the
top of the skull there oh never mind did
it crack it I mean it also fell
um
that's at the base of the skull I'm not
sure if that's from the interesting all
right so
I don't know I don't know if you'd be
walking away from that one
um I know some of you might like oh it
looks fine that is just a skull in
ballistic gel uh
that might hit that that I don't know if
that'd be good but
see what about the what about a shotgun
wait when did that happen is that here
oh you shot it again
uh I want to shoot the wish.com armor
another time
oh no
oh you were wrong
the center was the weakest fart
oh
foreign
was a good place to hit it at all Micah
I'm really scared to take this off
actually oh no
all right
so I think the answer is uh I don't
think that's going to save you not from
a magnum anyway so we have another
conclusion to make here we have another
conclusion to make here we this is our
first video right this is our first
video okay now what we're not going to
do right now is we're not going to go to
the suggested videos we're going to go
back to the home page because we as new
viewers don't understand how YouTube
Works yet right we don't know what the
next suggested video is going to be
we're going to see how this is changing
our perspectives but before we do that
we're gonna because I don't have an
account right now so I'd like
uh I'm gonna ask you guys
question is
nope nope don't nope here we go
would you click the like button on that
video I know we didn't watch all of it
but like I don't want to steal all of it
you guys can go see the video if you
want would you like that video would you
click like on that did that satisfy all
your needs did it was it true to what it
was advertising would you watch it again
would you do anything interesting
and fascinating
that is a pretty significant split in
the number of people that would like
that video because I'm not really a
person that goes around liking the
videos that I am watching like I really
know this is so this is so fascinating
because it's revealing the psychology of
how people like watch things like in a
weird interesting way because I thought
like this would be a completely
unscientific thing
yeah so yeah I'm I'm of the Mind where I
don't usually like things either so it's
kind of a weird thing where it's like
some people would because they're very
much like that but I didn't think it
would be that split I didn't think that
it would be like 55
fascinating but also I know that some of
you didn't vote for this video so that
might be there might be lingering
disdain so try to remove that from your
bias if you can but still 55 is a
fascinating discrepancy of the people
that would like this video
yeah
you're supposed to like good content so
you're saying that this isn't good
content or you just don't care about the
like button fascinating see the way I
look at the like button is I click it if
I would want to see more of that type of
video
and it's very rare that I do that but
the majority of the time I click it is
actually just like as a show of support
so I don't even really do it because I
don't know if it has any effect like
that but I'm kind of just like just as a
show support like hey I want to support
these guys here's a like I guess because
I don't know what it is fascinating okay
55 of you would click like all right
we're going back to homepage
so this is it what is this creators are
rewriting the language of Dance
celebrate International
fascinating okay wait is that a choice
would you guys click on Buster move
okay hold on wait all right so hold on
forget that thought here all right so
let's see how this so now we have
gravity knife a 250 000 Gun Room every
Mr Beast member who got fired U.S Navy
ships conducts live fire exercise
30 Queens Ken Martin who's Martin I
don't know I don't know fortune and fire
top 5 Deadly video game weapons extreme
solution US Navy found to deal with
enemy something dunk on me for five
thousand dollars
are this is this isn't this is
interesting
a real gravity knife one of the most
illegal knives to carry okay that seems
sensationalist this seems clickbaity why
would a I don't know but it's so
captivating because I don't know what a
gravity knife is and why is it illegal
this seems gratuitous and terrifying
given that there's a gun in the
thumbnail pointed directly at me
U.S Navy ship conducts live fire that
only has 256 views that was so six
six hours ago
oh my God
okay
then there's like okay I can see like
video game weapons extreme solution
there's a mystery there okay so we're
gonna break this down into a few
different and yes I I know there's bus
to move
I'm aware of that bus to move with this
there but hold on we're here
laughs
guys you need to settle I don't think I
think we probably have to sign up for an
account to bust a move I don't think I
could do that right now so what I'm
gonna do is we're gonna look
what's the second
video
so we've got gravity knife whatever that
means I think the Mr Beast fired
um chess some people are like really
about the chess and that I if unless I
can only put four so I'm gonna put
God please don't click that as like a
meme I I swear I don't think it's
something that could be done
all right
what's the second video
that's fascinating though
why it was chess for a while there it
was chest for us okay gravity
uh Mr Beast blossom
uh we could bust a move in the 250 000
Vault room
okay interesting uh but just to appease
people I am kind of curious of what this
is so while you finish up that pull I'm
gonna see what Bust A Move is
oh
oh God we actually have to I don't want
to learn to dance I don't wanna man all
of this would have music that would just
like destroy
my channel in an instant not that I
don't know that this stream won't
destroy my channel but I'm pretty sure
that this would destroy my channel in an
instant oh frick
oh frick I don't know if
oh am I like am I able gonna be able to
go back
oh no
oh no
ah what was it gravity knife I can look
that up okay this is gonna be uh okay it
was gravity no it's fine hey hey it's
it's fine there's a thing you just
discovered there's a search bar and you
can look up what a search bar is so we
can find there and see
there it is easy we're good we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good
50 cal versus
no I didn't ruin it nothing was ruined I
didn't blow it no it's fine this was it
it was Nev's knives
I remember that it's totally fine that
was Neve's knives whose knees the
experience is not tainted the experiment
might have been tainted when you got
your stupid too much in here but I went
my brain too down and then I wanted to
see what Bust the Move was but we're not
busting a move nothing it's not cheating
it's not ruined it's it's not ruined
because you didn't know how YouTube
worked and when you saw a bus to move
you were like oh this isn't what I want
so you went back
and then it changed it's kind of easy no
don't take my veto no no don't take my
pizza oh I haven't even used any of them
I haven't even used my vetoes you can't
take my veto
it's not a I didn't veto anything I
didn't veto it fine all right fine I'm
probably not even gonna get to all of
them anyway whatever
fine whatever I get two vetoes I haven't
even used it I didn't even used it I've
been going along with what you've been
saying I haven't even used it
all right whatever but gravity Nana are
you happy can we go to gravity or we're
gonna what is a gravity knife bang Nev's
knives I'm Jared and today we are
checking out a
ring gravity knife these are possibly
some of the most
illegal knives to carry now in most
places you can own them so you can have
them you just can't carry them now in
some places you can
so what constitutes a gravity knife a
gravity knife is something that can be
deployed with gravity and that is
exactly what this does so this is a made
by react and it is I can't put it on two
times speed you don't know what that is
you don't you don't know what that is
you don't you're learning we're learning
you pick this you pick this this cost me
a veto you picked this
[Music]
look it we just got it look how many
Cuts this guy says I mean he's a knife
guy I guess that makes sense the react
EXO comes in multiple different uh
versions meaning dude yeah do you think
this is illegal for us to even watch
this do you think that this is no you
don't know what 80 you you don't know
what ADHD is you don't know what 2x
speed is you're new we are new viewers
we're new we're new we don't understand
what 2x is but are you guys bored enough
because that is a thing
that is a thing are you guys bored
enough that you want to skip out do you
want to bail that's that's and that are
like board
okay I'll let it play as the poll goes
tell me so the way it works is you hold
the my card aside and let's look at the
machine work really quick though the
Machining on this is insane it's so good
well there's like a pivot down here
oh that's a good idea the titanium
because it's all titanium
you just let it
inside
is the blade and it's
slides
inside
free
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh boy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay all right I'll save you okay so
you're bored okay bored but we gotta do
our uh
sorry
uh would you like this video though
that's the question would you like that
video
would you like we're gonna go back but
would you like that video
foreign
no God it's crushing but but the
question is why did that video have
eight was it eight nine million views or
something like that
why did you have that okay so you guys
would not like that video I feel all
right okay all right whatever you say
[Laughter]
all right so clearly we have different
uh things here we've got now it's it is
painted we got Grand thumb again with
blow the lungs out of the body uh knife
versus bare hands a reality check the
band Italian switchblade I see where
this is going quenching a knife and
liquid nitrogen God damn how to speak
that was a bit of a that was a bit of a
out of left feel we've got an hour and
three minute I'll just speak
uh coil gun last thing you hear
um okay we did we did gun and we did
knife let's say that we're a little
bored
um
you want mistress you want Mr speak
you want how to speak sound melt brain
okay
okay we we got okay what is third video
okay we got how to speak very popular
apparently okay uh sound melt brain
there's no chess I I'm sorry to say this
there's no chess
um gadgets gadgets knife bare hand oh
man it's kind of split there uh
uh no I'm I'm kind of curious no one
really is looking for the liquid
nitrogen oh wait no there is okay
nitrogen
nitrogen
and then it's ah it's so hard to think
of what the
um
I I uh fine bus to move all right so we
okay so the choices are uh how to speak
sound melt brain nitrogen and bust a
move I should have said liquid nitrogen
I feel like nitrogen doesn't paint it
wow
that is fascinating
is currently 41 of you want to see an
hour and three minute course on how to
speak
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
all right you know what I don't even
need to let that poll go we're going
we're learning how to speak
oh God it's 0.5 speed oh God
let's go
let's go
bored you can't be bored it hasn't even
started uniform code of military Justice
specifies Court martial for any officer
who sends a soldier into battle without
a weapon
there ought to be a similar protection
for students because students shouldn't
go out into life without an ability to
communicate
and that's because your success in life
will be determined largely by your
ability to speak
your ability to write
and the quality of your ideas in that
order
I know that I can be successful in this
because
the quality of communication
okay all right speaking you're writing
oh man not that many people born no no
it's a matter of how much knowledge you
have how much you practice with that
knowledge
and your inherent talent and notice that
the team is very small what really
matters is what you know
this point came to me okay but we're
okay suddenly a few decades ago when I
was skiing at Sun Valley I'd heard that
it was a celebrity weekend and one of
the celebrities was a was American
Britain famous Olympic gymnast perfect
tense of the Vault and I heard that she
was an obviously scheme so when the
opportunity slope and saw this young
woman who when she became unbalanced and
I said that's got to be her that must be
the gymnast
but that occurred to me I'm a much
better skier than she is and she's an
Olympic Athlete not only an ordinary
Olympic Athlete an outstanding one and I
was a better skewer because I had the K
and I had to pee and all she had was the
two so you could get a lot better for
the people who me
uh
he had the k I hear the p
she had the tea
man this guy knows how to speak
God damn
all right wait we gotta see what the
most replayed is what's the most
thrilling part of this okay all right
and uh within the one microsecond the
Lord said not to show us they've got
some kind of vision quickly followed by
Bill who said they have a show that
they've done something
oh that sounds good I said and then I
said to them how long does the candidate
have to establish these two things what
do you think well compare your answer to
theirs
five minutes
so if you haven't expressed your vision
if you haven't told people you've done
something in five minutes you've already
lost
uh uh I don't know who's gonna tell this
guy
um
this video is a little longer than five
minutes
foreign
[Laughter]
so all of you have already lost we've
all already lost we took longer than
five minutes I think that is a lesson
for YouTube to understand uh but
I think it was informative
I think that was very informative I
think the qualifier of clicking that
like button
is very pertinent here because honestly
like what what does this teach us what
does this teach us what does this teach
us who we are
ah see I thought it was 100 no for a
second there I was like aha see Ethan
needs to watch this video yeah he
probably does but then again maybe we
all do maybe we all do now we're talking
okay all right okay we're going back to
the main page what do we got here
hmm I'm kind of curious all right we're
closing bus to move we're not all right
I'll leave it up but I don't wanna no
bus to move
um we have throwing a grenade in a
frozen lake
brand enhancement techniques uh trolling
chess Hustler into thinking I was a
beginner gravity knife versus OTF versus
whatever whatever Jamie Foxx on Robert
Downey Jr Mike Tyson boxing
perpetual motion machine testing shoes
that make you walk 250 percent faster
okay
so we got a weird mix I don't know how
it got this way I see some of the things
here
but I'm just gonna go what is fourth
video
so we've got
throwing a grenade in a lake
uh what else you want
chess God you guys really want the chest
I don't know why
um walking faster question mark
uh and then
Adam Savage okay that's good I'm not
putting bus to move on there
God damn you know this one I feel like
this is pretty obvious I feel like this
is just straight up easy I feel like
everyone here no we're not gonna bust a
move
I'm not gonna post the nut either you're
gonna you're gonna bust
you're going to bust a grenade yeah
you're gonna yeah that's what we're
gonna do okay this one's obvious like I
I knew okay okay everybody wanted me to
throw this grenade that's my grandpa's
frozen lake down there oh my God the
problem is it's so far out that way
I'm not that strong enough I don't think
anyone can actually throw it that far I
could throw it so what I'm gonna use is
this hang on
the real question
[Laughter]
because you gotta be honest now
be honest
could you throw it that far
that's the question
no I'm not going to keep it on two times
why do you keep wanting to put on 2X
why would you do that is that what you
guys do
you guys watch things at 2x speed
there's no way
no
there's no freaking way there's no way
are you kidding me
hold up hold on
are you telling me that there's people
in here that watch
YouTube always
at two what
what
okay all right that
that's so much higher than it should be
you can't watch this stream at 2x this
stream is One X only
you cannot
oh
no okay maybe that maybe
oh no
I can't stream it to his speed
oh no
I need another poll
oh no
so that was like always at 2x speed
I'm asking now do you mostly watch
YouTube at 2x speed
you Liars
there can't be less of you that watch it
mostly to ex unless oh God is that
oh no wait
oh no is that 13 more percent oh no hold
on hold on hold hold on hold on
oh no
hold on
I'm giving you options here and I'm
giving you options for a reason
because I need to know
you
you lie you Liars you Liars you're
embarrassed now you Liars you lied to me
you're lying oh you're lying oh you're
lying you're lying to me you're lying to
me you're lying oh you guys said 15 of
you said always before what did you
think that that poll was there's no
Integrity in these polls if only now
five percent of you always do it
because the qualification was 15 of you
always said you did and then I said
mostly and then it was suddenly 13
mostly watch it and now it's neither of
those things
who Do You Think You Are
what do you think you can pull on me
and I'm a fool I didn't turn my brain
off you did and clearly you did you're
embarrassed now oh yeah I didn't put 2.5
although we got a better pool we got a
better pool we can shoot dang it we uh
we got a better poll coming up what
okay we got it
what is the best speed
that's better
that's better now all things are
balanced in the world
way to go
normal is the way to go 1.25 is not the
best speed who does 1.2 1.25
what
1.25 why no
no
then everything is wrong everything is
slightly wrong God you're going to train
your ears to be that forever 0.75
there's not enough options for me to go
through all I'm vetoing this I'm vetoing
everything I'm vetoing all of you all of
you have just been vetoed I'm vetoing
you I'm vetoing everybody I'm taking a
veto to this there is the only best I'm
using up one of my vetoes for this oh
the only best speed is 1x I will not
take any arguments if you listen to 1.25
all the time you're going to destroy
your ears all of your you who think you
have perfect picture gonna be shocked
when you're off and you're out of tune
forever for the rest of your life you're
ruining your brain everyone who's not
listening at normal hates reality and I
can understand that but I can't respect
it I will have a full write-up of my
opinions about that and how much I don't
respect it in my follow-up video to
respect respect to respectable Boogaloo
okay whatever let's and Ken in let's
watch this made by X products it
launches stuff okay and it's going to be
launching one
two three fire and a hole
wait wait
hahaha
[Laughter]
that was incredibly underwhelming
yeah you guys were ahead of me yeah no
that was incredibly Wonder Woman that
was incredibly underwhelming
yeah man
that was a
I'm shockingly underwhelming see the
thing that I'm discovering how did I get
to one veto I didn't I don't know the
thing that the yeah exactly that is that
is incredibly disappointing the thing
that I'm discovering
is this
that
I think I know why YouTube doesn't just
show videos anymore that are so closely
related to what you were just watching I
know that they take into account your
watch time what you're doing uh uh like
as you're watching it whether you're
watching it in 2x speed I bet they take
that into account
because that video was disappointing it
was a lot of fluff to get to the point
of the whole video which was grenade in
a frozen lake because in your mind
you're like oh that's got to be super
super cool when in reality it was kind
of less cool than seeing a grenade
chucked into a canyon or something like
that or put a grenade in a pickle jar or
something like that
and now we have all these boring videos
see this is what you did this video has
no views and you got how to speak again
it knows you didn't finish it
oh man what even is this
no man
I mean that's pretty cool the dual
blades of Miyamoto Musashi
you asked for bus to move busting move
was not you can't watch how to speak
again
no
this is what we have what is the fifth
video okay all right is it dual blades
is it
let me have one other one
for God this is bad choices man this is
bad choices Japanese knife okay that's
cool that's cool all right
freaking Bust a Move
oh man you guys have ruined this you
guys have ruined this somehow I'm two
vetoes down and it's still no better for
this oh what have you done
no
oh
no
I'm gonna make you watch the whole thing
I'm gonna make you watch the whole damn
thing I'm gonna make no no God
oh my God
[Laughter]
oh my God I can't veto it I only have
one veto left what are you thinking
what are you doing this is why people
who work at YouTube HQ probably cry
under their office other than the fact
that they're probably extremely
overworked
it's because they know they have to
build an algorithm for Maniacs like you
they have to put together some software
that can try to predict what you want
you don't even know what you want you
want how to speak fine
it doesn't even remember where we picked
up because I don't have an account
oh please tell me well
let's see
oh yes there is one more thing by way of
uh the tools and that has to do with the
use of slides
I repeat
I think therefore exposing ideas not for
teaching ideas but that's what we do in
a job talk for a conference talk
all right let's try this mythical 1.5
speed so let me tell you a little bit
about my views on that
um
I remember once I was um
and um
Terminal A
at Logan Airport I just come back from
really replayed the gulp
oops
you play the goal
I remember my views on that so let me
tell you a little bit about uh where's
the gulp
feed
and that has to do with the uh
use some slides
our feet
that's quite a gulp
what about everywhere
0.5
this is so boring look you picked it you
picked it you picked it
all of you picked it okay oh
I forgot there was more
more
oh yeah shorts wait we've totally
forgotten a different area we've totally
forgotten a completely different area of
YouTube
we forgot that in 2023 YouTube has
shorts now
we forgot about this we forgot that
YouTube just isn't just about regular
videos anymore no the era of tick tock
is upon us and the era of YouTube shorts
is here
I forgot about that I literally did so
this is no we have to take I don't care
if you don't like shorts I don't care if
you don't like shorts
look I don't care this you're new you're
new you never even been on Tick Tock you
don't know what shorts is all you do all
you're doing is you're scrolling through
those videos didn't do for it those did
those videos weren't a part of it
those videos weren't anything about it
and so now
look
it's a fascinating
this is really telling this is extremely
telling
like what even is this
I I don't watch YouTube shorts I don't
at all the thing about it is I find that
YouTube shorts is a pure amalgamation of
content that is simply ripped from other
places
like this one even has a tick tock
watermark on it
and I don't even know like there's very
few oh oh there's
what
what is I feel like it's so tainted with
your previous choices see this is this
is where I said this before and this was
kind of like a rabbit hole that YouTube
sometimes go down where it can go from
like a completely new viewer and the
original objective of what I was doing
on this is how quickly
could YouTube send people to conspiracy
videos and now the question that I'm
asking myself is how quickly will
YouTube funnel people down to alt-right
videos like where does that go down it's
kind of like a similar pathway
to go there
it seems like there's this General Trend
because the First videos was like oh
will a bulletproof mask work will this
go here and there and yeah and wherever
it's fascinating right it's fascinating
because it seems so simple and yet here
it is I mean there's Jordan Peterson I
don't know what this guy's doing in a
mall with a military uniform this guy
says buy a shotgun it's fascinating
it's fascinating
it's fascinating Joe Rogan is this name
right
you want the bloody bear this see this
isn't this isn't about a bear it's Joe
Rogan talking about a bear but the the
for some reason there's a thumbnail I
don't think you can make custom
thumbnails on this yeah
exactly right
bear bear
anyone bear and Bear
bear
buy a shotgun
scammer
shotgun can we start over no that's the
thing you can't start over this is where
YouTube is sending new viewers
no not bear
liquid is there even dude oh Liquid
Nitro I didn't even see that one I
because I didn't read the the title at
all
I hate all of these see the thing is I
hate all these too not all of them
but I can see it's sending it down a
particular path
so what we're going to do is I'm going
to use my last veto here to try to steer
it in a way
that could go somewhere that I can be
proud of
and we're gonna we're gonna I'm gonna
use up my last veto
let's see why Asians never get scammed
as someone
who's Asian
let's see why maybe I could be related
maybe this could be relatable to Me
Maybe it could be hmm
foreign
I'm trying to offer you okay
I see how it is
you're sitting in your mom's basement
what do you mean you're calling me on a
off-brand jailbreak iPhone
what
I didn't really know you sound like
minimum wage you're wearing a fake Rolex
with a black strap for extra personality
how would you know that I'm expert in
philiology so you want to not be a
failure yes sir okay first send me your
bank details okay
wait you're not gonna steal my money are
you who would steal 2.60 you stick as a
dictionary how do you know my parents I
own the bank now I'm going to send you
enough money to buy a real iPhone so you
can subscribe to the channel okay
so I see you in class okay what class
I love I I do like
some of these videos
I do like yeah I is that the same person
that does Uncle Roger because I don't
know
what was it uh
uh all right oh God I forgot that you
just keep going
yeah
no yes no no no I didn't think so no not
not the same don't look like him yeah
not at all the same
no no no no no no no no no no no don't
be don't be so silly but hey that was
interesting would would you like can you
like you can like a short you can like
that would you like that video
or short I I got video showing I don't
you what it's still a video it's still
got video on it
it's still got video on it right
it definitely does yes see it was all
fun times I don't want to scroll
all right I guess I gotta scroll okay
Korea's around the back
Korea
well I am right so around the back
[Music]
I'm here to see Anna Miller
well you've got to sign in like everyone
else what's your name Laura
[Music]
when the hell was that was that was that
a movie is that the I haven't seen the
Laura Croft movie is it uh
I don't want to see a fight oh God I
don't want any of this I don't want any
of this
man where are we now we've got the oh
see there he is again that's interesting
this is
I've I've never been more depressed
after the results of one of these tests
because because really I was fine with
the videos and when on the videos go
wherever they go
I've I swear this video is haunting me
this even in my recommended this video
has been chasing me down until the end
of time like YouTube I I do like I love
like everyone love is a strong word but
I respect veritasium and I respect what
they do this video has been chasing me
that's what I don't understand about
some videos on YouTube is YouTube is so
convinced that I
want to watch this video and that
there's some videos out there that just
like absolutely must be watched however
I don't want to do that
okay all right let's do one more like
this this is really just like I'm kind
of I'm kind of like a man I just
something about just like going down a
YouTuber how to put Rabbit Hole ain't
the same as it used to be all right what
is our I'm out of Vetoes this is what it
is and this will be the only one okay
you guys want egg drop
you guys want sushi I saw
ghost is there a ghost one here
ghost what do you oh go like
okay all right ghost sure
uh chess there's no chess there is no
chess piano
Vibes I guess
piano
and then
the veritas
okay all right okay all right that's
what we got this is gonna be the last
video that we watch
this is where YouTube has sent new
viewers supposedly I only use my veto
once in the history of all that
okay it's handily egg drop I'm pretty
sure it's not even well actually
well hold on I I also opened that up and
I assume that it would be a clean sweep
it's not a clean sweep interesting
interesting okay it's very close but
it's still gonna be egg drop
I didn't put
I did put riddle that's the veritasium
one
it's close any last votes in is going to
be your last opportunity
ghosts should have one I I don't know
about that it seems like people want to
see the egg drop
all right three two
one
zero
okay
this is space and this is an egg moments
before foreign
okay
so obviously respect because there's a
huge amount of stuff that goes into
something like this
I just want to see a drop from space
this is one of those videos where I
don't know if I'm going to watch through
the whole thing whoa is that Nas
involved okay now I'm kind of curious
but at the same time not that curious
okay
or is it actually drop
where does it drop
where's the drop
what is this in no dance opportunity to
land a safe egg and fourth and finally
we went to a local Crane Yard to test
both our Solutions at their respective
terminal velocities starting first with
the beach ball okay this would make
sense because you have to go into the
whole science of like how you would do
that most replayed is that it
flaw in our brilliant plan and you're
doing terminal guidance to something
about the size of a house how are you
going to do that how do you do that I
mean I know how you physically do that
how do you not busted why is this
I don't think that's it where is it
where is it show me it this well as the
other guy here with Adam and he's the
one who actually said this touchdown
confirmed we're safe online
if we were successful he'd be the one to
make the official because the balloon
expands so large as it rises we realized
we could actually even spot it from the
ground which was awesome oh yeah I know
I see it yeah
dude that's that's totally it what
wasn't awesome was when moments later
Joe while looking through the binoculars
made this gut-wrenching observation
we saw it small yeah it like seems to be
smaller but it's just weird that it
would just completely disappear which
was followed by a devastating call from
the balloon tracking team it dropped
within the last two minutes
yeah that's 30 000 feet over the last
however so it's just popped but these
don't pop there's zero pressure and
that's true they don't pop but
unbeknownst to us while we were looking
at it from the ground the rocket and
beach ball had been spinning around and
around relative to the balloon for about
10 minutes this meant the cord that
attaches to the string that
self-destructs the balloon was getting
wrapped around Tighter and Tighter until
it was so tight it pulled down on the
balloon string that is designed to
essentially unzip and destroy itself and
so before we even have the chance to
release the rocketed beach ball from the
balloon it all started coming down in
one big Tangled Heap at 150 miles per
hour which is way faster than the eggs
could survive well let's start driving
ah
guys
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry
uh I don't know what to say
ghost ghost ghost ghost
oh wait
let's see good definitely touch down but
touchdown confirmed whether or not we're
safe on our this TVD right let's check
it out to be sure oh man
laughs
touchdown confirmed we're safe on Earth
it's a Twist it's twists every time it's
twists you never keep them always keep
them guessing you never know all right
God damn
wasn't clickbait after well it wasn't
clickbait in the first place
all right okay
so
what have we learned
I do enjoy
I do enjoy that you know you know what's
uh fascinating to me is that it has been
unlike previous things it's been a while
since I've seen like a a Mr Beast uh
like uh video being recommended and this
one isn't even the main Channel which is
which is interesting but I think like he
doesn't do too many gun related things I
think that really painted uh the way
that we do things so no no there's no
more busting a move there's no more
busting a move because
suddenly you realize that YouTube wasn't
the place for you when you clicked off
of it and you didn't make an account and
you didn't get there I don't think that
maybe the mark Rober one actually would
have been something that could have
hooked you and if we were to watch the
whole thing which is not what I'm going
to do if you want to see those whole
things you got to watch it for yourself
no no no no no no no no we're not
busting a move we're not busting but
we're not busting a move we we done did
anything we're not busting a move
there's no moves too bust We're not
gonna bust a move
could have bust anything We're not gonna
bust anything else there's no things to
be busted
so the only question there's one
question however to be answered at the
end of all this when we look back at the
journey that we've taken to get to this
point right here
you can't veto me you you can't veto me
you can't veto me
you can't you can't veto me no the
question is
did you
enjoy
this video
this content this rehashing of things
this look back into what YouTube is or
look forward into what YouTube is and oh
oh
Jesus Christ
oh man is it because we didn't Bust A
Move okay that's fair that's fair that's
fair I appreciate that and you can't
veto me there's no vetoing me there's no
you can't veto me
you can't uh you absolutely cannot veto
me I am un vetoable you did not get any
vetoes the audience doesn't give vetoes
chat doesn't give vetoes I get the
vetoes I can see the proportion of
people enjoying this video is going down
the more I say that how about that you
do give vetoes you could veto me all you
want you can be to everything you the
way you veto me is by clicking the like
button that is the button to veto me oh
don't do it
damn I thought it'll work anyway so
another year another lesson learned it's
an interesting development having shorts
thrown into the mix I had almost
completely forgotten about that
I'd almost completely forgotten about
that
because it's just it's a very different
thing the thing about Tick Tock is that
there is no way to browse like this on
the home page I know you can search for
stuff but having the ability to go
through like this is a little bit
different and especially seeing like
thumbnails of it present or is it no I
guess it's the same never mind I'm
stupid I'm an idiot we're not watching
any more videos you're on YouTube right
now you have the event you have the
ability to go watch whatever you want if
you want to go bust a move you go bus to
move you don't have to veto vetoing me
is clicking the like button no once this
ends you're free to go out in YouTube
and enjoy it in whatever way you want
you can delete your watch history on
YouTube did you know that you can go to
your history and you can look back at
everything you just well well I can't
but you can clear all of your watch
history and you can clear all your
search history
and then you can make it so that it's
your fresh experience all over again and
you can watch all the videos you want
you can go wherever you want
I noticed that I wasn't suggested at all
here
I can't believe it
why is it
my videos
that's my videos
where's me
why am I not here
where am I how far until I get to a
Markiplier video
where am I
because I don't do anything gun related
where am I
where am I
am I not here
guys I'm
I'm here right
right
I'm I'm here I'm recommended I'm
I'm
recommended I'm I'm they would recommend
me
they would they would
I would recommend my
Channel it would definitely yeah they
would
yeah
ah there
yeah you're right
I'm not even
here
okay
oh
I'm not even on the gaming tab
what
what
wait hold on wait a minute hold on hold
on a second
this is the same
this is the same this is the same I got
to refresh it that's that's the problem
I gotta I gotta refresh yeah yeah this
is get me here so get me
uh
okay
live
oh it's the same that's weird that it
I'm it's the same four why is this is
because the gravity knife is put in
there that's what it is
what it is
ah
I don't exist
I don't exist
I don't exist
oh God
oh God
oh my God
oh
God why are there only three on the live
section why are there only three
channels on the live section what is
that about I have no okay whatever all
right so I've been vetoed from YouTube
thank you all for that I appreciate that
really thank you so much for that that
warms the cockles of my heart and if you
don't know what the cockles of my heart
are don't misconstrue that for anything
but what it is
um
so I've been in vetoed from YouTube and
my the cockles of my heart are
completely cold
I have very cold cockles
but thank you everybody so much for
being here have a lovely day uh this was
an educational experience I don't know
what the education was and I don't know
what we learned uh but all I know is
that
uh
things are different
thank you everybody so much for watching
I guess the only objective now is to try
to get me back on the front page and I
don't know how to do that everyone needs
to go go get a VPN uh go to the homepage
and click until you find my videos and
then watch only my videos that's
literally the only way to get me back on
the front page because there's I there's
absolutely nothing so you need to figure
out what it wait so hold on don't leave
don't leave wait what is don't uh what
is the distilled recipe for my channel
it's clearly not guns uh whatever else
we watched it's not how to speak because
I already know how to speak that's
probably the one thing about it is that
I already know how to speak so it's comp
it's competing videos
so what is the distilled version of who
I am as a person that's going to get you
to my videos what what is uh what is
what is uh what is it what is it what is
it I don't I busting a move will not I
don't bust moves so I don't think this
is gonna get Minecraft I don't play
Minecraft so that's definitely not gonna
get me now part two meow too I don't
know I don't know I don't know about
that look how to talk know how to speak
is not gonna get in there but what you
have to do is you all have to go open up
new tabs Incognito tabs you gotta turn
on your vpns you got to go to YouTube
and you just gotta find my videos that's
all you got to do you just gotta find my
videos you have to find my videos
because if you don't find my videos I'm
going to be wiped away from the face of
forever
if if I lose relevancy I'm going to
disappear into the ether and never
return
that's the only recipe that's gonna
happen to me so you gotta help me out
you gotta
you gotta all right
I'm gonna go
did you really veto what did you Retail
Me
did you
did you tell me
did you tell me
oh
my God